we have to talk about
the thing you've kind of mentioned
already a bunch of times but
doing computation
through chemistry chemical based
computation
i've seen you
refer to it as
in a sexy title of
kemp
mutation computation
so what is computation what is
chemically uh chemical based computation
okay so computation is a
a name i gave to the process of
um building a state machine to make any
molecule physically in the lab
and so as a chemist chemists make
molecules by hand
and
um
and they're quite hard the chemists have
a lot of tacit knowledge a lot of
ambiguity it's not possible to go
uniformly to the literature and read a
recipe to make a molecule
and then go and make it in the lab
every time some recipes are better than
others but they all assume
some
knowledge
and it's not universal what that is like
so it's uh carried from
from human to human yeah some of that
implicit knowledge and you're saying can
we remove the humor from the picture can
we like a program
well by the way what is a state machine
so a state machine is a i suppose a
a object either abstract or mechanical
where you can do
you can
um do a unit operation on it and flick
it from one state to another so a turn
style would be a good example of a state
machine
a there's some kinds of states and some
kind of transitions between states
and it's um
very
formal in nature in terms of because
precise yes you can mathematically
precisely
describe a state machine so i mean you
know a very simple boolean
gates are a very
good way of building kind of logic based
state machines
obviously a turing machine the concept
of a turing machine where you have a
tape and a read head and a series of
rules in a table and you would basically
look at what's on the tape and if you're
shifting the tape from left to right and
if you see a zero or one you look in
your lookup table and say right i've
seen a zero and a one um i then do um
i then respond to that so the turnstile
would be is there a human being pushing
the turnstile
in direction clockwise
if yes i will open let them go if it's
anticlockwise no so yes so state machine
has some labels and a transitions
transition diagram
so you're looking to
come up with a
chemical computer to form state machines
to to create molecules or yeah
what's the chicken in the egg so
computation is not a chemical computer
because we talked a few minutes about
actually doing computations with
chemicals yeah what i'm now saying is i
want to use state machines to transform
chemicals and so
to build chemicals programmatically yeah
i mean i get in trouble saying this i i
said to my my group i shouldn't say it
because this but i said look we should
make the crack bot it's in the crack
robot the real the mixture the crack
crackpot the robot that makes crack but
maybe we should scrub this from
but
or uh well so maybe you can educate me
on uh breaking bad with like math right
yeah so in breaking bad you want to make
you want to make um
basically some kind of mix of ex machina
and breaking bad
no i don't i don't record i don't but
you don't i said that's what i'm going
to do once you release the papers
but i shaved my head
and i'm going to
live a life of crime anyway i'm sorry no
no um so so yeah let's get back to so
indeed it is about making drugs but
importantly making important drugs um
drugs matter yeah but let's go let's go
back so
the basic thesis is chemistry is very
analog
there is no state machine
um
and i wandered into the through the
paper walls in the in the japanese house
a few years ago and said okay hey
organic chemist why are you why are you
doing this analog they said well
chemistry is really hard you can't
automate it it's impossible
i said but
is it impossible says yeah and they said
they said you know i got the impression
they were saying it's magic
and so when people tell me things are
magic
it's like no no they can't be magic
right so let's break this down and so
what i did is um i went to my my group
one day about about eight years ago and
said hey guys i've written this new
programming language for you
um and so everything is clear and you
know you have to you're not allowed to
just wander around the lab willy-nilly
you have to pick up things in order go
to the balance at the right time and all
this stuff and they looked at me as if i
was insane and basically kicked me out
of the lab and said no don't do that
we're not doing that yeah and i said
okay so i went back the next day and
said
i'm gonna find some money so we can make
cool robots do chemical reactions
everyone went that's cool yeah
and so in that process
the first to try to convert the humans
to become robots and
next you agree you might as well just
create the robots yes but so in that in
the formalization process yeah so what i
did is i said look a react chemical to
make a molecule you need to do four
things abstractly i want to make a
chemical turing machine because a turing
machine you think about this imagine a
turing machine turing machine is the
ultimate
abstraction of of a computation because
it's been shown
by turing and others that basically a
universal turing machine should be able
to do all computations that you can
imagine it's like wow
why don't i think of a turing machine
for chemistry let's think of a magic
robot that can make any molecule
let's think about that for a second okay
great how do we then implement it and i
think it's right so what is the
abstraction so to do
to make any molecule you have to do a
reaction so you have to put reagents
together do a reaction in a flask
typically
then you're after the reaction you have
to stop the reactions you do what's
called a work up so whatever cool it
down add some liquid to it extract so
then after you do the work up you
separate so you then remove the molecule
separate them all out and then the final
step is purification so reaction
workup separate purify so this is
basically not my exactly like a
um a turing machine where you have your
tape
you have your tape head you have some
rules and then you run it so i thought
cool i went to all the chemists and said
look chemistry isn't that hard
reaction work up separation and
purification do that in cycles forever
for any molecule all the chemistry
done
and they said um chemistry is that hard
i said but but just in principle
and i got a few very enlightened people
to say yeah okay in principle but it
ain't gonna work
and this was in about 2013 2014
and i
i found myself going to an architecture
conference almost by accident it's like
why i'm at this random conference on
architecture
and that was because i published a paper
on inorganic architecture and they said
come to an architecture conference but
the inorganic architecture nano
architecture
and i went okay and then i found these
guys at the conference 3d printing ping
pong balls and shapes and this is
through it 3d printing was cool and it's
like this is ridiculous why are you 3d
printing ping pong balls and i gave them
a whole load of abuse like i normally do
when i first meet people how to win
friends and influence people and then i
was like oh my god you guys are geniuses
yeah and so i got from they were a bit
confused because i was calling them
idiots and then called them geniuses
it's like
will you come to my lab and we're going
to build a robot to do chemistry with a
3d printer and say well that's cool all
right so i had them come to the lab and
we started to 3d print test tubes so you
imagine you know 3d print a bottle and
then and then and then use the same
gantry to basically rather than to
squirt out
plastic out of a nozzle have a little
syringe and chemicals in so we had the
3d printer that could simultaneously
print the test tube and then put
chemicals into the test tube
and then oh it does really end to end
yeah that's like that because they've
got g-code to do it all it's like yeah
that's cool
so i got my group doing this and i
developed it a bit and i realized that
we could
take those unit operations and we built
a whole bunch of pumps and valves and i
realized that i could basically take the
literature
and i made the first version of the
computer in 2016-17
i made some architectural decisions so i
designed the pumps and valves in my
group i did all the electronics in my
group they were brilliant
i
i cannot pay tribute to my group enough
in doing this they were just brilliant
and there were some poor souls there
that said lee
why are you making this design
electronics i'm like well
because i don't understand it
like so you're making us design stuff
because you don't understand it's like
yeah it's like but can we not just buy
some
i said well we can but then i don't
understand how to you know
what bus they're going to use and
there's serial ports and all this stuff
i just wanted and i made i came up the
decision to design a bunch of pumps and
valves i used power over ethernet so
you've got one cable for power and data
plug them all in plug them all into a
router
and um and then i made the state machine
and there was a couple of cool things i
did all they did actually um
we got the the abstraction so reaction
work up separation
purification
and then i
made the decision to do it in batch
now as in batch
all chemistry had been digitized before
apparently every once it's been done but
everyone's been doing it in flow
and flow is continuous and their
infinity is everywhere and you have to
just and i realized
that i could actually make a state
machine where i basically put stuff in
the reactor
turn it from one state to another state
stop it and just read it out and okay
and i was kind of
bitching at electrical engineers saying
you have it easy you don't have to clean
out the electrons you know because
electrons don't leave a big mess they
leave some em waste but in my state
machine i built in cleaning so it's like
would do all operation then it cleans
the backbone then can do it again so
there's no there's any so what we
managed to do over a couple of years is
is develop the hardware develop state
machine and we encoded three molecules
we did three the first three we did
nitol with sleeping drug refinamid
anti-seizure and viagra
you know and i i could make jokes on the
paper it's a hard problem blah blah blah
yeah that's very good and then and then
in the next one what we just said okay
my poor organic chemist said look lee
we've we've worked with you this long
we've made a robot that looks like it's
going to take our jobs away
and
and not just take our jobs away that
what we love in the lab but now we have
to become programmers but we're not even
good programmers we just have to spend
ages writing lines of code
that are boring and it's not as elegant
and when you're right
so then
but i knew because i had this
abstraction
and i knew that there was language
i could suddenly develop a state machine
that would interpret the language which
was lossy and ambiguous and populate my
abstraction so i built a chemical
programming language that is is actually
going to be recursively innumerable it's
going to be a turing complete language
actually which is kind of cool which
means it's formally verifiable
so
where we are now is we can now read the
literature using a bit of natural
language processing it's not the best
many other groups have done better job
but we can use that language reading to
populate the state machine
and basically add subtract there's a
we've got about a number of primitives
that we
the
you know basically program loops that we
dovetail together and we can make any
molecule with it okay so that's that's
the kind of program synthesis so you
start like literally you're talking
about like a paper
like a scientific paper
that's being read
from natural language processing
extracting
some kind of
details about chemical
reactions and the the chemical
molecules and compounds
involved
and then that's
that
in gpt
terms serves as a prompt
for the program synthesis that's kind of
trivial right now there you have a bunch
of different like for loops and so on
that creates a program in this
chemical language that can then be
interpreted by the
chemical computer
the computer yeah
yeah
everything sounds better in your uh
british accent but it's i love it so the
into the computer and that's able to
then
basically be a 3d printer for these for
molecules yeah i wouldn't call it a 3d
printer i would call it a universal
chemical reaction system because 3d
printing gives the wrong impression but
yeah and and it purifies
and the nice thing is that that code now
that we call it chem the kdl code
is
is really interesting because
now so computation what is computation
computation is
what computing is to mathematics i think
computation is the process of taking
chemical code and some input reagents
and making the same molecule making the
molecule
reproducibly every time without fail
what is computation it's the process of
taking a using a program to take some
input conditions and give you an output
same every time
right reliably so the the problem is now
maybe you can push back and correct me
on this
so i know biology is messy
my question is how messy is chemistry so
the if we use the analogy of a computer
it's easier to make
computation
in a computer
very precise that it's repeatable
it makes errors almost never it's it
does the exact same way over and over
and over and over what about chemistry
is there messiness in the whole thing it
can that be somehow leveraged can it be
controlled can be that removed do we
want to remove it from the system oh yes
and no right there's is there messiness
there
there is messiness because chemistry is
like you're you're you're doing
reactions on on billions of molecules
and they don't always work but you've
got purification there
and so what we've found
is at the beginning everyone said it
can't work it's gonna be too messy it'll
just fail and i said but you managed to
get chemistry to work in the lab are you
magic are you doing something
so i would say
now go back to the first ever computer
or the eniac five million soldered
joints four hundred thousand uh valves
are exploding all the time was that
would you have gone okay that's messy
so we've got the and
have we got the equivalent of the eniac
in my lab
we've got 15 computers in the lab now
and they are they unreliable yeah they
fall apart here and there but are they
getting better
really quickly yeah are they now able to
reliably make are we at the point in the
lab where there are some molecules we
would rather make on the computer
than have a human being make yeah we've
just done we've just made a
um anti-influenza molecule and some
antivirals
um six steps on the computer that would
take a human being
about one week to make arbidol
um of continuous labor and all they do
now is load up the reagents press go
button and just go away and drink coffee
wow
so this i mean
and this is uh you're saying this
computer is just the early days and so
like some of the criticisms just have to
do with the early days and yes i would
say that something like this is
uh
quite
impossible
uh you know so the fact that you're
doing is is incredible not not
impossible of course but extremely
difficult it it did seem really
difficult and i do keep pinching myself
when i go in the lab i was like is it
working like yep and it it's not you
know it does clog
it does stop you gotta clean this is
great
you know but it's um it's getting more
reliable because i made some we just
made design decisions and said we are
not gonna abandon the abstraction think
about it if the if you the von neumann
implementation was abandoned i mean
think about what we do to semiconductors
to really constrain them
to um what we do to silicon in a fab lab
we take computation for granted silicon
is not in its natural state we are
doping the hell out of it it's
incredible what they're able to
accomplish and achieve that reliability
at the scale they do like you said
that's after moore's law we'll have now
and
we you know
uh how it started you know so
we started at the bottom now we're here
we have only have 20 million molecules
say 20 million molecules in one database
maybe a few hundred million in all the
pharmaceutical companies
um and those few hundred million
molecules are responsible for all the
drugs that we've had for humanity except
you know biologics for the last 50 years
now imagine what happens when a drug
goes out of print
it goes out of prints because there's
only a finite number of manufacturing
facilities in the world that make these
drugs yeah isn't that computer the
printing press the chemical chemistry
yeah
and and not only that we can protect the
kdl so we can stop bad actors doing it
we can encrypt them
and we can give people yeah that's the
name of sorry to interrupt is the name
of the programming language the kydl is
the name of the programming language and
the pro code we give the chemicals so
chi as in you know just
for it's like a it's actually like an
xml format but i've now taken it from
script to a
to a fully
expressible programming language so we
can do dynamics and there's four loops
in there and conditional statements
right but the structure it started out
as a um
like a like an xml thing yeah yeah yeah
and now we also the chemist doesn't need
to program kdl they can just go to the
software and type in add a to b reflux
do what they would normally do and it
just converts it to kindly l and they
have a linter to check it and everything
sorry how do you um
you know not with ascii but because it's
a greek letter how do you go with
um how do you spell it just using the
english alphabet we're just like
xdl or we use we put in kai and it was
named by one of my students and i and
one of my postdocs many years ago and i
quite liked it it's like
it's important i think when the team are
contributing to such big ideas because
there are ideas as well
i try not to just rename i didn't call
it cronin or anything that because they
keep saying you know is a
um is a the chemistry when they're
putting stuff in the computer one of my
students said we're asking now is it
cronin complete and i was like what does
that mean i said well can we make it on
the damn machine
and i was like oh is that is that a
compliment or a majority but they're
like well
it might be both
you